have you ever found much inspiration for
your videos being here i have really yes
i have oh [ __ ] okay okay okay okay
you're gonna tell me have you ever tried
to uh work on them yet i i've started
have you actually i thought you were
okay the other day you were complaining
you're like i can't work
when
what day was this oh like like five days
ago show me the response five days ago
yeah it it's been like really busy
because we're like trying to get our
life together do you have your gaming
chair
is that is that the last thing is that
the reason why you can't work because
you don't have a gear diver said he
can't work cause he doesn't have a good
chance yeah i can sit on the chair just
fine right
now you say that as if dennis looks at
the charities like what do i do how do i
watch this where do i put my back i can
sit on the chair just fine but
it's also like
lately i've had to like wake up early
for stuff like for appointments yeah so
then i have to go to bed early
right wow you get used to it normal time
schedule now it's like you have a
schedule yeah japan kind of got me off
the degenerate hours sleep schedule yeah
we have commitments we need to do things
geeks possibly like emily turn up here
at 9 a.m
i get to like midnight and i'm like [ __ ]
man i'm way past my bedtime people rely
on us for a schedule now like you wake
up at like [ __ ] one and that's like
half the day gone wake up to like 50
slack messages i'm like
oh my god how many do i have to reply to
now but uh yeah like what was your sleep
schedule before you moved to japan then
was it like a degenerate house i would
go to bed at like four oh my god and i'd
wake up at like
ten because i'm eleven we used to play a
lot of league before you moved uh and i
would be like it's like 3 p.m here
she'll probably send like 5 a.m in the
u.s and i'll be like yeah
you want to play league no yeah
right away
i'll be like all right
all right cool we have to play tft again
yeah we were like addicted to tft
but these boys right never play that
don't ever try it i don't
get tft team fortress 2
[Laughter]
explain explain tft to the best your
ability yeah
sell tft doors oh my god i've played it
once and i'm just like i do not get this
i'm sorry it's like right on me
like aimed up or something you know
uh tft
is a game in league of legends yes
uh i'm a league player by the way i just
don't understand auto chess i'm not a
league player it's a gridlock
you get characters you buy what is it
similar to i don't know what game is
similar to
no he's not going to help me
yeah yeah you gotta
manage your gold every round and you try
to build the strongest team you can by
buying characters and leveling them up
so it's like balloons tower defense sure
i don't know yeah
it sounds like balloon style i like it
because it's chill and like how can you
get toxic playing a cute little i don't
know i get i can get toxic
yeah i know yeah but that's just yeah
that's true don't don't don't make
anything you don't make that a challenge
i'm sure some people can find a way
i don't know it's fun though it's pretty
chill it's a good game to like chat with
because you kind of like it's pretty i'm
not gonna lie i deemed no information
so i can't even be like yeah
it's kind of like it's literally like i
mean the best way to describe to you is
that like it's a gacha roll constantly
sold it's literally it is literally like
imagine okay you are literally a gacha
players to manage their wallet and and
the the interest of the economy to make
sure that you can do it
so like no winning at every every every
turn you get five choices right and you
have x amount of gold yeah and you can
buy some of the characters but it'll
mean you have less gold now then get
your credit card
promise you can't add money the only way
you can add money is by winning
fights
and getting a streak of winning or
losing right or no
or you get like interest so you save
money right but the gadget part is that
like you can you can if you're like all
right i have 50 gold
i think i can get this one character
within 20 gold if i don't do it i'm
broke and my game is ruined so you start
rolling and every time you refresh it
costs two money so you get like stuff
like so it's like balloons tower defense
if you could pick your unit every time
yeah and then like let's say you get
three of the same tower yeah it evolves
so and then if you want to evolve it to
level three which is like the max one
you have to get like
two level uh three level two so you just
get nine total right right right and the
more you take it's shared amongst all
the other players so if you all go for
the same balloons tower defense
character
if someone else is going for it as well
the odds of you getting it when you
reroll is lower so imagine get your
players where if god got the ssr yeah
now you have way less chance of getting
the ssr oh [ __ ] so there's like a
strategy to like all right if i want to
[ __ ] gone over i don't need this
character but i'm so rich that i can buy
up this character to [ __ ] with god all
right and make sure ghant can't get it
you can definitely see how that can
become toxic yeah it's great yeah it's
really frustrating because there's no
communication so when you see another
player buying all the [ __ ] you need and
they clearly don't need it you're like
if i can sell units right now the
economy is crashing because of you
it's fun though yeah and there's a lot
of down time because it's automatic so
when your turn is over you kind of don't
do anything for like a minute or two
minutes you can just watch the battle
yeah so you can kind of like tour you
can type you can send messages it's
pretty that's my problem with like
playing like i guess
multiplayer intense competitive games
it's not like i'm not like also like
playing with friends because i'm that
guy who's just like [ __ ] at multitasking
uh when i'm playing a competitive game
yeah right because like me playing
league with friends is just just me
[ __ ] like just dumbed out i i do not
hear anything i hear pings and that's it
i think the good thing about tft i'm
sorry i know i'm selling it here but i'm
just trying to give reasons to why i
enjoy the game
you can put as much like i have to pee
okay you can keep talking but i have to
pee
i'm sorry
the thing i like about tft right now i
i'll stop talking about it because i
know it's resident sleeper it makes
people [ __ ] bored to death
i'll just gush about it a little bit
right the thing i like about it is that
you can put as much
like
multitasking and like thinking as you
want i feel like we'll me you and us all
play the game slightly different
right like dydus literally does not give
a [ __ ] what anyone else is doing he
literally is like i like this team i'm
gonna go for it no matter what and he
builds it every single time every single
game and like normally loses because
you're supposed the idea is that you're
supposed to like strategize around
what's going on changing adapt yeah and
then i feel like you're like kind of in
the middle where it's like you like
comps and you kind of like swap around
and you kind of pay attention to what's
going on and then like if you really
really want to like focus i can't do
this very well but like people you'll
watch them play the game they're
literally flicking between every single
player and seeing what they're buying in
real time and buying like accordingly
yeah they'd probably be good stock
traders if they yeah was about to say
something productive
you know like the you probably need like
[ __ ] five screens just yeah every
enemy all at once right
it's it's really like hard because you
have to like
learn
to like not be attached to anything in
that game like if you like a team and
you're like oh i'm building this perfect
team if you're really good at the game
you can be like right [ __ ] it we're
starting again let's get rid of this
team let's get another one stop rolling
let's not get you rolling right i mean
that's how your window i don't know
that's the most awful part of gacha
though you've got to get emotionally
attached you've got to get emotionally
touched otherwise why would i throw down
my credit card yeah well luckily in this
you have to spend money here except
except for on skins where they charge
you like egregious amounts for skins
you'll have these little stupid [ __ ]
things in the game that are like your
avatar it's like 20 bucks for one gacha
roll of to get one not 10 like one
i did a gacha roll to get 10 eggs which
all contain one it was like it was like
a hundred bucks
for a ten
yeah so jesus christ yeah so you know
so you basically just paid for a hundred
dollar game
i should weigh more than a hundred
dollars
i spent i've spent over like two grand
on league i'm not proud of saying that
but geez emily's probably spent two
grand on luck skins that's not true i
have those bot friends who's your main
the eagle classic
i have a luxe sugar daddy she literally
did you know that meme of the of the
girls going honey it's time for your 4
p.m dick fun
i edited it where it's me and itis yeah
honey there's a new luck skin out
can't believe you don't buy your own
skins
i don't believe it can't believe it the
audacity wow i buy other people's skins
too
yeah you probably buy them the [ __ ] ones
the luxe ones are like five five hundred
dollars for like a fancy particle effect
no they're not
i'm guessing your main is lux then yes
she literally only plays that
i like syndra too
i just literally like literally joey
knows those guys i know this character
unfortunately none of them are in arcane
joey this is there's a joke there's a
joke in league right that all
girls play lux
i know ahri oh yeah
all those [ __ ] kpop videos yeah and
all the head ties yeah
she's cute why'd you like lux um she has
a magical girl skin of course of course
of course now it makes sense when i
first started playing league i was like
flipping to the characters who do i like
i like annie at first world cuz she's
easy to play yeah yeah and then i i
tried playing caitlyn i liked her too
right but they're all kind of the same
of like a lot of them are like oh i want
to be powerful i'm so strong and
powerful
and then lux is really cute she's like
she's like positive a magical girl i
hate her voice
she's just like she's just like a bubbly
nerd and it was so endearing so
basically she's just you yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
for real she's just like me
emily has the habit of getting really
attached to characters that are just her
yeah yeah you know like
like tauro from fruit basket is like her
favorite emily can you assume that she
doesn't have a like
if she
she doesn't swear or has like a loose
side or whatever how dare you assume
that emily i'm kidding
she's a whole human being